hi guys sci-fi recap here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2020 american action and drama movie
called we can be heroes
the movie begins with a hero called
miracle guy heading out on a mission
with another hero called techno
miracle guy goes to outer space to scout
for the mission
there he finds the satellite has been
broken by an armada of aliens
he goes to fight them immediately but
unfortunately he loses and falls down to
earth as techno catches him
the scene moves to a girl who just wakes
up named missy moreno she then has
breakfast with her father marcus moreno
who turns out to be the leader of the
hero while watching the news about
miracle guy
after that marcus drops missy at school
and then he goes to the heroic
headquarters
there the director granada plans to
counter-attack the aliens by sending two
heroes
marcus explains that they need all of
the heroes since it is an armada of
aliens
because of that the director agrees to
deploy all of the heroes including
marcus himself
marcus rejects the idea of sending him
to fight since he promised his daughter
that he won't go to fight again
granada insists that he goes to fight
and eventually he accepts the idea at
school everyone asks missy to use her
heroics power but because she doesn't
inherit powers from her father she can't
and refuses to show them
suddenly missy is picked up by heroic
agents to heroics headquarters
arriving there she is escorted by the
director to the basement vault missy
meets the other heroics kids there
wheels who possesses super intelligence
noodles who can stretch his body oh ho
who is mute and communicates through art
acapella who can move objects by singing
slow-mo who is always in slow motion
face maker who can make any face rewind
and fast-forward twins who hate each
other that can alter time wild card who
has immense power but no control over it
and guppy who has shark strength and can
control water
after they get to know each other the
kids watch the battle between the aliens
and heroics on television but
unfortunately all of the heroics are
lost and captured by the aliens
marcus contacts missy saying that he's
sorry as he goes to fight the aliens and
also gets captured
later president nelly anami gives a
speech on the news saying that the
aliens will take over the earth and they
have three hours left
then vernada orders them not to leave
the room
missy realizes that ojo's drawing tells
the future and she notices a drawing
where the aliens break into the vault
because of that the kids plan to escape
from there
facemaker tricks the guards into coming
into the vault and then guppy subdues
them
unfortunately one of the guards manages
to trigger an emergency lockdown
trapping them inside as the aliens are
coming in
rewind sends them back in time and
wheels immediately stops the guard from
pushing the button they immediately go
out but mrs granada spots them in the
hallway and seals the doors
acapella makes a staircase using the
guards to the roof allowing them to
escape
they secure a vehicle then a cappella
makes it fly and the kids escape
a few moments later they land at the
home of anita moreno missy's grandmother
who is the heroics trainer
she helps the kids to understand how
important it is to work as a team
she then chooses missy as a leader and
brings the kids to the training field to
train
however missy leading the kids fails and
she feels very sad about it as her
grandma comes to her and consoles her
anita tells her daughter that the
strongest hero from heroics is her
mother who doesn't have any superpower
but her mother is strong with her
leadership to lead the heroics after
that the aliens arrive and anita sends
the kids through a secret tunnel not
long after that anita gets captured by
the aliens
meanwhile the captured heroics is
prisoned by the aliens and it seems like
they don't have any teamwork as they
always mock each other
in the tunnel missy borrows os ipad to
plan their next move by seeing their
future
she then shows wild card the future that
they will find an empty alien craft and
use it to reach the mother ship
then he shares their next plan to the
kids they find the alien craft and
immediately go to the mother ship
arriving there wheels uses missy's
communication bracelet to locate their
parents they start to explore the area
but unfortunately the aliens know they
are coming and manage to find the kids
they run from the aliens and reach a
room with a pyramid where they see the
president talk about the takeover
suddenly granada approaches the kids and
says that she's proud of them and all
the events are at trial ojo then shows
missy her ipad that granada is actually
an alien the president arrives in the
room and turns out they are alien spies
sent to prepare earth for the takeover
the kids are then imprisoned by the
aliens
meanwhile the heroics get a visit from a
mysterious creature and attack them
turns out the mysterious creature is
anita and she immediately scolds the
heroics as they don't have any teamwork
missy gives a speech to the kids so that
they are tearing up and takes this
opportunity to collect the tier and
gives it to guppy guppy then makes a key
and opens the door
meanwhile techno manages to turn on the
security monitors where they find their
children escaping
missy suggests the team go to the
pyramid and cancel the takeover first
but wildcard disagrees as he says that
they free their parents and let them
handle the rest because of this wild
card and face maker separate themselves
with a team
not long after wildcard and facemaker
argue and then they split up
seeing this vernata immediately goes to
capture wildcard since he's the only one
who can't control the power the aliens
catch up to the kids and surround them
the kids have no choice but to fight so
they use their teamwork to fight the
aliens because of the situation missy
orders guppy to enter shark frenzy mode
which she does and she manages to damage
the aliens the aliens then bring out
their tentacles and manage to handcuff
the kids
rewind and fast forward manage to help
each other and turn the situation around
this time the aliens are the ones who
get handcuffed on the leg
then they go to the pyramid room where
suddenly a force field emerges and
protects the pyramid and oho tells them
that she is the one who activates it
granada manages to capture wildcard and
she interrogates him to let her know
about their big plan
turns out the captured wild card is
actually facemaker who deceives the
aliens the real wild card is already in
the control room just as missy planned
knowing this granada immediately goes
after the wild card oho then reveals
herself to be the supreme commander of
aliens but missy already knows since
they are in the tunnel where ojo
accidentally reveals herself in the
drawing she made
after that wild card manages to
deactivate the force field granada
arrives and orders the aliens to attack
wild card but wild card is different
from before as he can control his power
now and manages to defeat all the aliens
including granada by freezing her
because there's a little time left oh ho
tries to stall the times and draws a
bunch of aliens to attack the kids
rewind and fast forward combine their
power and manage to make slo-mo become
so fast to attack the aliens debbie runs
out of water at the same time wheels
tells her that the pyramid is made of
liquid metal she creates a shark from
the liquid metal and manages to defeat
the rest of the aliens oho immediately
summons more aliens from her drawings to
set an example as a leader this time
missy goes out to fight the monster with
the help from noodles as marcus watches
her from the security monitor she
manages to lure the aliens into stepping
to noodles stretched hand with missy's
commands noodles then releases his grip
and both the aliens and missy fall down
but noodles manages to catch missy and
brings her up
seeing this all of their parents are so
moved and proud of their children
wheels manages to create a motherboard
that will cancel the takeover
when he passes it to noodles ojo creates
a tentacle and it hits the motherboard
and it falls down
noodles tries to take the motherboard
down below but he can't reach the goods
to secure the motherboard slo-mo jumps
down and manages to get the goods
after that missy calls wildcard to get
there which he immediately goes there by
teleportation he then brings slo-mo up
and then they manage to remove the
motherboard on top of the pyramid and
change it with a new one and
deactivating the takeover
suddenly the pyramid opens and oho says
that they are too late and the takeover
is happening turns out the one that
comes out from the pyramid is all the
heroics oh ho reveals that she and all
of the aliens fake the takeover to train
the kids to be the new heroics they hope
that the new heroics will protect not
just earth but the galaxy as well thus
ojo makes an alliance with the new
heroics the kids then reunite with each
of their parents as they miss and hug
each other like a child and parents ever
have at the end of the movie the new
heroics are ready to protect the world
and galaxy
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching